tout de suite la revue de presse
avec vos accès mais ce matin bonjour
axel bonjour on commence avec ce geste
important d' emmanuel macron à l'égard
des anciens francs c'est ce qu'on
appelle communément les pieds noirs nés
en algérie qui était à l'époque un
département français et qui ont connu
ensuite pour la plupart l'exode lors de
la guerre d'algérie
les pieds noirs viennent d'obtenir des
manuels macron une satisfaction sans
précédent explique l'historien guy
pervillé dans le figaro le journal
rappelle le contexte cinq ans après ses
propos polémiques sur la colonisation le
président de la république a reconnu
deux massacres commis après les accords
d'evian celui du 26 mars 1962 rue d'isly
à alger lorsque l'armée française a tiré
sur une manifestation favorable algérie
française tuant des dizaines de
personnes et le massacre avec un bilan
encore plus lourd du 5 juillet 62
perpétrait lui par les algériens contre
des européens mais sans que l'armée
française intervienne si tu es toujours
par le figaro guy pervillé auteur d'une
histoire iconoclaste de la guerre
d'algérie poursuit emmanuel macron a
choisi de s'avancer sur le chemin de la
reconnaissance mémorielle mais jusqu'ici
il ne reconnaissait letter de la france
qu à l'endroit d'un seul camp donnant le
sentiment d'une mémoire biaisé
n'accordant d'intérêt comme victime
tombée du côté des ennemis de l'algérie
française fin de citation aussi la joute
assurément alger ne va pas apprécié les
propos tenus par emmanuel macron
ajustements je suis allé le voir dans la
presse algérienne avec l'aide de la
rédaction arabophone de france 24 et on
y parle de la crise politique qui n'en
finit pas de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée de la crise sanitaire de la
coupe d'afrique des nations mais rien
sur cette prise de position du président
de la république française une prise de
position des manuels macron certains y
verront un acte de campagne
présidentielle même s'il n'est toujours
pas officiellement candidat à sa propre
succession oui et justement puisque vous
évoquez la campagne présidentielle du
mois d'avril sachez que c'est
aujourd'hui que débute la course aux
parrainages et c'est là une de l'opinion
combien seront ils sur la ligne de
départ le nombre de candidats dépendra
de la collecte des soutiens il faut au
minimum 500 parrainages d'élus la liste
définitive sera officialisée le lundi 7
mars et vous avez ici françois hollande
1 qui s'est montré cette semaine et digg
matic sur une éventuelle candidature
surprise
expliqua ils reprennent à la celle qu'on
pourrait symboliser comme la république
française ne vous précipitez pas il peut
y avoir encore des surprises
la course aux parrainages lancé en
france autres épreuves sportives au
pluriel pour le coup celle qui commence
dans huit jours maintenant à pékin pour
les jeux olympiques d'hiver et la presse
chinoise s'en fait l'écho oui le china
daily montre en une la première
génération chinoise de médecins du ski
et oui ce sport est à l'état
embryonnaire encore en chine et ses
médecins nous explique que le le
quotidien anglophone chinois ces
médecins ont été formés en tant
qu'intervenant d'urgence pour prodiguer
les premiers soins aux skieurs alpins
qui se blesserait lors des jeux d'hiver
des jeux ou la diplomatie n'est
évidemment jamais loin à la une du temps
en suisse pays la suisse a connu pour sa
neutralité cet éditorial le covan a ôté
une sacrée épine du pied au conseil
fédéral arguant que la situation
sanitaire est incertaine le gouvernement
a décidé opportunément de n'envoyer
aucun des siens assister à la cérémonie
d'ouverture des jeux olympiques de pékin
explique le temps et il jure un
qu'aucune considération politique
n'explique sa décision le gouvernement
suisse en tout cas elle permet un hôte
dans cet éditorial assez sarcastique à
tous les acteurs de sauver la face et
d'éviter des tensions avec la chine et
puis en quelques mots de bleu blanc
rouge les porte drapeau de la délégation
tricolore ont été dévoilées oui c'est à
lire dans l'équipe tessa worley en ski
alpin kevin rolland ski acrobatique et
le biathlète benjamin davier pour les
jeux paralympiques commentaires de kevin
rolland il ya dix ans aucun skieur
freestyle n'était dans le paysage des
jeux d'hiver cela montre le chemin
parcouru free style j'aime beaucoup si
bruxelles c'était la revue de presse on
se retrouve très vite